Why are pizza boxes square?
Because square is what's in right now...
Hey you, come over here.
Even though pizzas are round, square boxes are preferred.
Why?
This is because a square box is made using just a single cardboard sheet.
While a round box requires several sheets.
That need to be joined together using special machinery.
So it is cheaper and simpler to make square boxes.
Yes.
A square box can be easily assembled on-site.
They are transported in the form of flat cardboard sheets easily stacked on.
However, round boxes need to be first assembled.
This makes it difficult to transport and store these huge pile of boxes on-site.